I'll never forget 2015 when my life
really shifted because I had three main
freelance clients one was paying me 2
000 a month the other was paying me 2
000 a month and one was paying me 1 000
a month I make it about 60 dollars a
month in YouTube ad revenue and the
first week of October 2015 a client
calls me and says Sean we gotta let you
go and that was one of the two thousand
dollar clients and then the second
client called me and said Sean we need
to let you go so in three weeks I lost
three freelance clients it was at that
moment that I called a business mentor
of mine his name's David he goes Sean
there comes a point in your life when
you need to jump off the cliff but it
sounds like God just kicked you off the
cliff and now it's your time to fly I
posted 52 videos in the next two months
my income in just two months was almost
five thousand dollars and so the five
thousand dollars I had lost from my
client work had been replaced because I
put in the hustle